MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So in this lecture, we
talk about nuclear fusion.
And what we mean by fusion
is the energy production
by two light nuclei
fusing together
to produce a heavier one
which is more tightly bound.
And again, we can understand
this from the empirical mass
formula, OK?
So the difficulty
in nuclear fusion
is that we now have to
overcome the Coulomb
barrier from the other side.
So we have to bring two
light nuclei together, have
to overcome the Coulomb barrier
in order to form this heavier
and more tightly bound state.
You might think
that you can just
take a two beams of protons
like we do at the LHC,
bombard them, and
create heavier nuclei.
But the problem is
that most of the nuclei
will scatter
elastically, and will not
lead to a new-bound state.
So the practical way to
overcome the Coulomb barrier
is by creating a confined
mixture and supplying heat,
such that the thermal energy is
enough to overcome the Coulomb
barrier.
You can estimate how
much energy is needed.
If you, for example, assume a
Coulomb barrier of about 5 MeV,
this implies temperatures of
5 times 10 to the 10 Kelvin.
OK, so that's really,
really hot, right?
If you compare this to typical
temperatures within stars,
you'll find that those are
only 10 to the 8 Kelvin.
So now you ask, why
does it still work?
Why do we see fusion
within a stellar medium?
And the answer to this is,
again, quantum tunneling,
and to some degree,
it's also the fact
that when we have a medium
of a specific temperature,
the kinetic energy of
the particle involved
follows a mixture of
energy distribution.
So you find some particles
which have enough energy
to overcome the
Coulomb potential.
Even so, the mean
value would be below.
The processes
within the sun, they
are dominated by so-called
proton-proton cycle, or PPI
cycle.
And this happens in
a number of steps.
You start with
hydrogen or protons--
the core of the sun
is basically a plasma.
So we can forget about
electrons in this context.
So we have two protons
fusing together
to a deuteron, which is
a proton and a neutron,
via the weak interaction.
Here, you find for the first
time, again, the neutrinos
being produced in the sun.
Then, you supply
the deuterium again.
And together with
the proton, you
are able to produce the helium.
And then the helium,
again, is being
used to supply the
third step in this.
Helium-3 is supplied
to produce helium-4.
So this then-- the end product
is a helium-4 here, and energy.
You combine all of
those three steps,
you find that you start
with four protons.
You produce helium-4 plus
positrons, neutrinos, photons,
and energy.
In fact, as I was
just saying, this all
happens within the hot plasma.
The positrons are
basically annihilated
with electrons, which
are part of the plasma,
adding another MeV
of energy to this.
All right, this is one, and
the dominant energy production
mechanism within the sun.
But it's not the only one.
Also quite interesting is
the so-called carbon cycle.
It's contributing about 3%
to the sun's energy output.
So here, carbon basically
works as a catalyst.
So you have a carbon and, again,
a proton producing nitrogen.
The nitrogen produces
carbon-13, carbon-13 together
with a proton nitrogen-14,
14, nitrogen-14 with a proton
oxygen-15, and oxygen-15,
nitrogen-15, and then,
last but not least, nitrogen-15
together with a proton
produces carbon-12
again, and helium.
So you see that the carbon-12
is the catalyst here,
which is used to produce
helium and energy.
So if you produce this cycle,
that you combine this cycle,
you find that, again, from four
protons or four hydrogen atoms,
you produce helium, positrons,
again, neutrinos, photons,
and energy-- very
similar, it's visible,
to this combined chain,
with the exception
that there is one
additional photon.
And again, here, the positrons
supply additional energy
and they annihilate
with electrons.
Great, so we have seen
that we do two things.
We create heavier forms of
metal starting from hydrogen,
and we produce energy.
And so this is the energy
production mechanism
within the sun.
This is nice.
You produce-- you start
with hydrogen or deuterium.
Those are two elements
which are very abundant.
And you produce energy.
So the question comes
up whether or not
you can actually
use this on Earth,
in a controlled
environment, in order
to produce energy and solve
many of the ongoing issues we
have on this planet.
There are several
efforts underway.
And this goes back all
the way to the '50s
of the last century.
The most prominent one currently
is the so-called ITER project,
which is international
collaboration,
and a project where one
tries to build a fusion
reactor in France.
I can already tell you that
the next stage for this
is in about five years
to complete the project,
or complete the production of--
construction of the
project, and produce energy
for the first time
with this project
in this controlled environment.
It will take another 10,
15 years on this road
map of research in order to
produce, or be able to produce,
nuclear power reactors--
nuclear fusion
power reactors which
can be used in some
sort of commercial way.
There's a few other
interesting projects
which use different
magnet technologies which
might have a more faster
pathway to success.
But coming back
to the story here,
so you could start
with protons again
in a proton-proton reaction.
But it turns out that this
is a rather slow process,
and not very promising
for a controlled reaction.
But deuterium or tritium
are also very promising.
Note that, for
deuterium here, you
have to overcome the same
Coulomb barrier, right?
The charges involved
are the very same.
But the cross
sections are higher.
And therefore, the likelihood
for the process to occur
is higher.
And therefore, this
can happen much faster.
Deuterium is-- again, as I was
saying before-- very abundant.
You can just extract
it from water.
Tritium is a little bit more
difficult to deal with--
to produce and to
control because it's
radioactive and has some
really not so good features.
But this is a model
picture of ITER.
Again, this is an
international project.
It has a rather bad
reputation these days.
It's by far the most
expensive scientific endeavor.
But again, I mean, I
think this is investment
to the future of this planet.
And hopefully it will
succeed in the next years
with this project,
and in the long run
with having nuclear fission--
fusion avail--
sorry, nuclear fusion
available for energy creation.
What you see here is--
the key feature of this
reactor is toroidal magnets
which confine the plasma.
And also, electric
fields are used in order
to heat the plasma up first.
So you have to provide
heat to a point
that the heat being produced
in the fusion process
is sufficient to self-sustain.
And so confining the plasma
and providing enough energy,
and the radiation in
this and so on, this
is all very difficult
problems to solve.